[Music]
crime has to be fixed we have to build
up the morale of the police department
we have to make people like the police
again or the people that are out there
that do speak up and we have to change
and get some of these politicians out of
office
that are hurting and killing the people
[Music]
it's very difficult because it's the
first time
in history that you had all three
entities of government
turn their backs on the police and i
mean on a city level a state level and a
federal level
the
opinion of the police department
suffered
unfairly in my opinion
[Music]
but
since then
they're
it's not as vocal it's still out there
it's just not as vocal as it once was
just walking in the street you know
even even myself i don't wear a uniform
i wear a suit they associate myself
either to homicide or to the fence and
that alone gives us the attitude from
the street but
you know having done this for so long
we've developed thick skin it's very
trying
for the detectives out on the street
they're out there doing their job uh
during a very difficult time well in
2001 we had 7 200 detectives
and today
we have 5200 detectives
so we're short a couple of thousand
detectives and that directly affects the
safety of the people of new york city as
well
there are people carrying firearms
illegal firearms in the streets of new
york city at an alarming rate
uh and we're making the arrests we've uh
arrested almost 5 000 people thus far
this year our county illegal firearms 82
percent of those individuals that were
arrested were let back out onto the
street they're arrested
uh after great work done by detectives
in every borough they're arrested and
they're literally released the next
morning
bail reform laws allow them to be
released and
they hit the streets back the next very
next morning there have been cases where
individuals have been arrested for
firearms
released
and they've been arrested more than once
and they were released and they
committed a murder
or
shot someone uh and we know these
individuals because of the the
encounters we've already had with them
so the defunding of the police
uh didn't work uh just like the laws
that were passed
in albany you're not working
it's just that our elected officials are
not adult enough to realize or admit
they made a mistake and fix what they
broke well it's the new york state
senate and new york state assembly are
they the ones that passed the bail
reform laws that created all this crime
if they would have fixed the bail reform
and just give judges the discretion
to keep
violent criminals in jail
that would have an effect if they would
change the discovery laws
uh where witnesses and complainants are
not afraid to come forward
that their names are going to be
released and they're going to be put in
harm's way that would fix a lot of
problems and
there's a law on the books if you're
caught with an illegal firearm it's a
minimum mandate of one year in jail and
you're not enforcing those laws if you
fix those three things the shootings in
new york city will drop dramatically i
mean we need everyone from the top all
the way down to support the police
department because at the end of the day
we're out there day in day out fighting
the battle and we need the support from
from
for the politicians everyone if the next
mayor whoever it may be
doesn't fix the crime epidemic in the
city of new york
the economic machine of this city will
come to a halt
and the city will fall
it'll go back to days that you don't
want to see and we haven't seen
in many many many years